cool well thank you very much for the
kind introduction gareth
and i'm very very pleased to be here um
so yeah i'm brendan mcginnis i'm the ceo
of sorcery
and i founded sorcery because i love
refactoring codes and
like any good programmer i eventually
got to the stage where i wanted to
automate the process
so that's what sorcery is all about it
automatically
refactors code as you're writing it
and it really acts like a pair
programmer that's sat beside you
reading the code as you write it
understanding it and then just tapping
you on the shoulder and saying
hey here's a little improvement you can
make and then you make the improvement
to your code
and you carry on going so
that's not what i'm here to talk about
today
today we're going to talk about
functional programming
we're going to talk about how we can
take existing python code
and refactor it so it's written in the
functional programming style
and i'm going to demonstrate this with a
live coding example
where i take an existing implementation
of notes and crosses
and refactor it into the functional
programming style
and this will show us what functional
code looks like in python programs
how we can introduce it into an existing
program
and then we'll talk about some of the
benefits
so before we do any of that
gareth will you play me at naughts and
crosses
all right all right i'll give it a shot
go easy on me here
okay so i will go
first so i pick a square from one to
nine
so let's go with two okay
so i think i will go for the middle one
so that must be number five right
five okay i will go
with one
that must mean i have to stop you at
three
oh blocked okay
so i will go for seven
ah typo
so that that makes my life a lot easier
so that i will go for seven then thank
you very much
oh well played okay so i really need
some undo functionality in this
right let's play one more time
let's see how we get on second time
round first the two
first the two okay you can go first so
i'll go for
the middle one so i think five i'm a
happy person in the middle
okay i will go for eight
so therefore i will go for number nine
okay i gotta stop you in one
and i will go for three
ah you fought me
and then i i make it uh yeah so i go
then for
six right six
ah lovely okay you win you win okay
what i'd really like to do is watch a
replay of that because you absolutely
thrashed me
so we've got some new requirements for
this game
want to be able to undo the last move
and let's say by typing u
we can show a replay of the whole game
by typing r
so let's check out the code
so this is what we've got there's
a main function this is the main logic
so it says input a square from one to
nine
creates a new game and while the game is
not finished
we read the next move apply the move
and display the game and keep going
until the game is finished
and then finally we display the results
so that's nice and simple
and then we've got a player class for x
and o
which is a string enum and then we've
got this naughts and crosses code
okay so it's storing the turn who's
playing next
and it's storing the position as a list
of
either nuns or player x or o
and then when we play a move we update
the position
and we swap the turn and then we've got
a couple of check functions so
here's the game finished if there's a
winner then there is
or if all of
the squares are occupied then the game
is finished
and then we have the winner code so this
checks if
all of the columns or rows or diagonals
are all of
the same type so all player x or player
o
and if there is there's a winner we
return that winner
and then finally we've got the display
code so this prints out the position
and then we print out the result
so let's think about this let's jump in
and add the undo functionality straight
away
how can we do this well we could
when we call the move
function we could just store the last
position
and we could store a list of all of the
moves
yeah let's store a list of all the moves
and then we can just add an undo method
to notes and crosses
so whenever the player types you then we
call undo
and then we undo the last move we turn
the position into what it was before
and then for a replay we can just create
a new notes and crosses object
play through the moves again display the
position
so that all sounds good
so shall we get started
whoa there stop this is not what we want
to do
whenever we make a change to code it's
always a good opportunity to refactor
so it's always better to refactor first
before adding new features
then it's easier to add the new
functionality so
in case you don't know refactoring is
the process of restructuring existing
code
without changing its external behavior
so once we've refactored notes and
crosses it's going to have exactly the
same functionality
but it's going to be easier to extend to
add the undo
and the replay functionality so in this
case we're going to refactor it into the
functional programming star
so we're going to talk about two aspects
of functional programming
pure functions and immutable data
so a pure function has two properties
it's referentially transparent
so that means if we pass in the same
arguments
then we get the same result
so it can't depend on non-local
variables that change
we can't have any mutable reference
arguments
so for example if we pass in a list to
the length function
then if we pass in an empty list then
length will return zero but if we then
append to that list
then the length will have one so that's
an example where
the list is a mutable reference argument
and another example is
self in this case in noughts and crosses
when we call the move method
we're updating the self
we're updating self and so that's why
when we call
the display function it will give a
different
output each time and then the other
thing that we can't do
is read from input streams
so in this case we're reading from the
command line but it could also be
reading from the database or reading
from the network
and then the other property is no side
effects so we can't
update um
non-local variables
mutable reference arguments or input
output streams so it's this
is similar instead of reading it's more
about writing
from these things and so an important
aspect about pure functions
is if we call another impure function
then the calling code is automatically
impure too
so it's tainted once something is impure
if anything else calls it it's also
impure
so we have to build out pure functions
on top of pure functions
so let me give you a summary of what a
pure function is
do not read or write mutable states or
the outside world
and do not call impure functions
so then the other aspects we're going to
talk about is a immutable data
structures
so this just says data cannot be changed
after it has been created
so in the naughts and crosses case we
wouldn't be allowed to call
the move method that updates the state
and if we have immutable data structures
it makes it much easier to create pure
functions
and we'll see that scene
so let's look at the code to see some
examples
so input that's not
referentially transparent because we
call it with the same argument
and it gives us a different result in
this case
we're typing in one to nine it's giving
us a different result each time
the int function this is a pure function
it only depends on what we pass into it
so that's very nice
move so it updates the result
it updates the state of notes and
crosses so this cannot be a
function and additionally it's also
printing out so
it's writing to an output stream
and then we've got display and display
result
so both of these print out so again
they're writing to an output stream and
they're not pure
okay let's look at winner so this looks
pretty good
it's the only thing it's depending
on is well it only depends on its
arguments
it doesn't write any state but there is
a problem
it depends on self.position and
self.position
is mutated in the move method so
we can call winner on the same object
and we get different results
and then the final thing to know is
noughts and crosses is not an immutable
data structure because we've got this
move method that's updating the state
so if we've got all this input printing
and updating state
how can we turn this into functional
code
so hold on
i would like to introduce
the functional core imperative shell
pattern
so the way this works is all the domain
logic
all of the business logic of your code
it lives in the functional core
and we only use pure functions and
immutable data structures
and then surrounding that is a very thin
imperative shell
that handles all the interaction with
the outside world and contains beautiful
values
so it prints to this to the command line
it reads the input
maybe it writes the database
and it could contain changing
changing state as well and so the
important aspect is the imperative shell
depends on the functional core
but not vice versa and that's because of
that aspect of
if something pure if something calls
something impure
then it automatically becomes impure so
that's why we have this diagram of the
imperative shell
wrapping the functional core
so how do we achieve this with existing
code we start from the inside and we go
outwards we start with the domain logic
in the core of the program
and then we make it functional and then
we push any imperative code
outside of that and then we keep going
layer by layer
until there's a really clean split
between the functional core and the
imperative shell
and you'll know you'll have achieved
this when all the domain logic
lives in modules which have no side
effects or mutable states
and all imperative code lives in other
modules which call this functional core
domain logic
so let's get back to notes and crosses
what are we going to aim for
we're going to turn the naughts and
crosses class into an immutable data
structure
and turn all of its methods into pure
functions
and then we're going to move all of the
printing and mutable state
into the main function simple
so it's live coding time
so one thing i always like to do when
i'm writing python code
is include type information and type
information always makes it much easier
when we're refactoring code
so the main function doesn't return
anything
so it's result type is none and when we
ever have code where the result type is
none it's a very
strong indicator that
the code is impure and in this case it's
quite clear
it's calling prints and it's displaying
results and it's reading information
so if we go to notes and crosses init
methods
always
return none and
let's set the turn to player
and the position is a list
of optional players
so i just need to import this
so the square's an int and
it returns none okay so that's another
indicator that this is an impure
function
so finished looks as though it returns
true or false
and winner returns either the player or
none
so it's an optional player
and display again
returns none so this is impure and
display result also returns none
so that's impure two so all of these
methods that are returning none in
noughts and crosses
there's a clear sign to us that these
are impure and we can see that because
they're calling prints in all cases
so let's have a look let's refactor this
code
so first thing to do is
let's see what this is okay i've got
source reinstalled
it's giving me a refactoring suggestion
how convenient
so let's have a look the function can be
refactored with the following changes
i have an english description and then
at the bottom
i can see the code change so that's
quite simple
i'm going to apply it and that
looks quite clear i can actually make
this
even simpler
so it's either winner or all the
positions
and winner is actually an optional
player but we should be returning a ball
so let's just wrap that in ball so that
code is nice and clear
and simple and here's another sorcery
suggestion
okay let's apply that
great so now let's move on to these
imperative
methods so let's start with display
result
so this one's quite simple what we're
going to do is
we're going to return a string and then
in the main code we're going to print
that string
so let's turn that to string
and we're getting a warning from my pi
which is telling us
that this is not returning a string so
if we just turn this
into return
nice and then where we were displaying
the result
we can just print it and actually
this is no longer displaying the results
so let's rename the function as well
okay
so let's try a display this is the same
sort of thing
we're going to return a string and
we're going to have to accumulate the
result here so we'll start with
an empty string
we're going to add each result
and then finally we're going to return
the result
okay so sorcery has picked up another
refactoring so
let's have a look at this okay
that looks a lot simpler using an if
expression
so i'll apply that and then because
this is a string enum the position is a
string
enum then i can actually remove this
value
and then actually sorcery is offering me
another suggestion
so let's apply that and that becomes
simpler still
and let's inline this
and then actually because one of the
things that we've achieved by removing
the print statement is now we're
working only with strings and so we can
use all of the string functionality
and string functions that come with
python so in this case we can actually
use
string.join so let's
do that
oops
okay suddenly this code is starting to
get much clearer
okay so there's a something going on we
haven't actually printed this yet
so let's print it
and actually printing display well
actually we're printing the game state
and in this
case the game state is really the
representation of
what the game is so instead of calling
game dot display
let's rename this
to dunder string so when we call print
game it's actually calling the string
method
so let's just test things out to see if
it's still working
okay excellent
right then now it's on to the big one
we've got the move method and this is
the one
which does all sorts of things is
printing and it's updating state
so firstly let's get rid of the print
okay so the way that we're going to get
rid of this is
we're actually going to raise an
exception instead and say
this square is already occupied
and then in this game code
we're going to check for that
and we're going to print it and actually
we need to declare this duplicate
move exception
okay so that's the first step but then
the more challenging step
is well if we can't update the state
hello hi brandon i think you dropped out
there a few seconds so if you wouldn't
mind going a little bit back in your
talk
i think there's a dropout on our end so
you were just about to change
the the move state so if you can go back
maybe 10 seconds in your
talk that would be great yeah okay
so is this the right spot yes
yes that's good thanks okay so
that's all right um
yes so the move is going to print out
the square but we need to remove that if
we're going to make it pure
so instead what we're going to do is
raise an exception
say this position has already been moved
and then we're going to print that
we're going to catch that exception and
we're going to print it in the main game
loop
so if we raise an exception
and
capture it here
and the other thing we need to do is of
course
declare that exception
okay so that's the easy bit then
the difficult bit is if we can't update
the state of
noughts and crosses how can we possibly
make this move
method work so there's a trick that
happens all the time in functional
programming
which is that we instead of updating the
state we return a new version of noughts
and crosses
so let's start
by saying that we're going to return a
new naughts and crosses instance
and actually we're going to have to pass
in the new turn and the new position
so the new turn is quite simply this
what was previously updated with the
turn
and the new position is slightly more
complicated
we'll take the existing position
and copy it
and then update the position for that
and then the problem is that nuts and
crosses doesn't take a new turn a new
position
but we can quickly set that up
and we're going to add default arguments
so that
if we don't pass anything in it still
um sets it up as it was previously
actually let's call these turn and
position
okay so let's test this
ah there's something wrong okay we've
called move and now we're returning a
new notes and crosses
but here it's not doing anything we
actually need to
update this existing game so let's
just set that like this
okay excellent excellent
so we've reached this ideal we've got
the functional core
we've got the nuts and crosses code it's
completely
immutable data we never update the data
and all of the methods are pure
functions
and then wrapping around that is this
imperative shell
where all of the input and output codes
exists
and all the state the mutable state
exists
so now it's much much easier to extend
so let's add that undo
functionality that we were talking about
so how we gonna do that well quite
simple thing we could do is just store
the history of all
the moves
so there's the starting move and
whenever a new move is taken
we just add it
and then we want to undo
so if the action is
oops
let's
drop the last move and then replace
the game with the previous position
so let's try that out play some moves
and then i can undo them
okay if i undo the first move there's
causes an error
so let's just check that the history
is greater than one so that
if we undo at the start
it doesn't do anything
okay excellent and then final thing to
do is add replay
so this is going to be really easy as
well
let's ask if we want to show a replay
and if the user says yes
then for all position in history
let's print the old
and let's just sleep for one second
between each of those
okay so
gareth let's play again all right that's
all
winner takes all the challenge accepted
very good so are you playing first am i
playing first
uh you can play first so i'm gonna go
for five
okay i'll go for one
um i would like to go for
two two okay i'm gonna block you at
eight
and then i go for three
okay i'm gonna block you again and then
i
go for uh
six no i can't nine nine
i have to you're right i have to block
you right
oh you've left the gap
ah yes
ah where was the mistake that's the
question
i'm not quite sure
well let's call it a drawer overall
let's call it a draw
well played well
okay so what are the benefits of this
functional programming style
so the big one is testing because pure
functions only depend on their
parameters
and have no side effects it's extremely
easy to test
we just pass in some values and check
the output
think about the display and string
methods on noughts and crosses
previously they were printing which is
always very messy to test
whereas now they return a string and so
we can just check that the right string
is being output
and then even the winner and the finish
methods are much easier to test now
because we can create a new notes and
crosses class in any position because we
the naughts and crosses init method now
takes a turn
and a position so we can set that up and
test those very very simply
so the second advantage is reusable code
so we've already seen right there how
easy it was to repurpose functional code
in this case to add undo and replay
but also let's think about the display
and string methods again
previously they were always printing to
the command line
but now we could save that output in a
file we could send it over the network
we can do whatever we like with it we've
separated out the printing
from the actual logic and so it's much
easier to reuse
and then the final benefit is functional
code is simple to understand
the great thing is it's just very very
easy to reason about
we only need to consider the arguments
to a pure function
to work out what the output will be
there's no chance that another part of
the function
sorry another part of the program will
change the state under our feet
and so there's a limited surface area to
read
to work out exactly what's going on
so in summary functional programming
we've got pure functions which are
referentially transparent and have no
side effects
and we build them around immutable data
structures
once created they never change
secondly always refactor your code
before you add new
functionality because it makes
everything easier and then finally
use sorcery to help you refactor
thank you very much very good very good
so brandon there there are there are a
few questions that came through that i'd
like to take the opportunity
to to ask you so one of the questions
that came through is um
someone mentioned that this is even
though it sounds like a very simple
example of notes and crosses and it
illustrates a common thing that people
push for time they code things and then
they get it working um but then they
don't
the question is this refactoring it
seems like it's always a burden to to
refactor
and the question is in your experience
um
do people really go back and refactor
enough and what are some best practices
that maybe organizations can adopt
to kind of create an environment where
refactoring is a good
good thing so you showed it in a simple
example the code started off being hard
to explain and then you made changes and
it become a bit easier and at a certain
point
nice and easy to read and also made your
life easier to change things
in your experience what does makes some
good practices companies should adopt
and teams to kind of
get this philosophy going
i think the first thing is to start
with your own code make it first the
practice for yourself
so whenever you're writing code think
actually i'm probably going to spend the
same amount of time writing this
if i first refactor it into a good
structure
and then i can add the functionality and
so over time
as you build up this muscle this
refactoring muscle you become better at
it
and you start to build up some evidence
that this is the case
people will start working with the code
that you've worked on and go oh this
looks really nice
how has this happened and then you can
say to people
well i always refactor my code i make
sure it's very nice
then i add the functionality and so
building like
a groundswell of opinion within your
team is often a good way to go
talk about refactoring do it a lot if
you're pair programming
always refactor with your pair
and get it going and then once you have
a a group of people who are with you on
that
then it's something that you can take
upwards and say look i think we should
actually
do this as a regular practice there
should be some time allocated to
refactoring
as well as just the time that we spend
when we're writing code
right right that's good that's good um
so thank you for that
and then the next question that kind of
came up is um
uh it seemed that in a simple example
and i'm sure you don't
do this or you do kind of were testing
manually so you're hacking your testing
right
well hacking's maybe a strong word but
you were testing as you go
right um do you have any thoughts on
should there be more unit testing would
it have been a nicer edition or did you
on purpose not show unit testing because
you were you wanted to prove functional
programming as opposed to
to how to better test card yeah i mean
i fully recommend getting your code
under test before
refactoring so
as you can see i had to go back a couple
of times to fix
mistakes that i had made and the testing
would have
found that out so firstly the type
information helps you identify some of
the errors that you introduce when
refactoring
but tests are much more powerful at
doing this so
in the sorcery code base we refactor
the functional core of sorcery
mercilessly we're constantly refactoring
and making it better
but we have very very high test coverage
of
that functional core and so we can make
very aggressive changes to the code base
because we know we're covered
and we know whenever we make those
changes if we make any mistakes
then they'll be spotted by our tests
so yeah i actually recommend writing the
test first
then refactoring and then adding the
functionality
very good and then there's another
question that kind of came through
is um so you you're you're the founder
of sorcery right so this is a very
powerful tool
um it seemed like you used it seamlessly
in your workflow can you maybe
tell us a little bit more about what's
behind is there's some secret magic
source behind this
and how should we use it so
is this only something for visual studio
code or can you tell us a little bit
more about it because it sounds like a
pretty useful tool for
everyone to to kind of learn as they go
along the same way you did it
yes so can you can you see me
i was just yes presentation yeah
absolutely
so it's available
for pycharm and vs codes that's
what we fully support and then there's
also integrations
for vim which i was using just now
sublime
um and emacs actually although i've
never actually tested that so
i hope that it works that was a
a user contributed integration
yeah so the other place that actually
works is we have a command line
interface
that allows it to be integrated into a
ci pipeline
and we also have a github bot
that reviews pool requests and suggests
refactorings on any other changes that
have been
made um but yeah
actually the integration in vs code and
pycharm is a lot
smoother and cleaner than the one that
we saw in bim there
and has some additional functionality
like being able to scan
a whole folder to find all of the
refactorings there
or scan for duplicate code across
part of your code base so yeah i really
recommend
just downloading sorcery checking that
out and
seeing how it works and send me an email
with any feedback that you have i'd love
to hear it
nice nice so while we were talking one
last question came through and then
we'll
well while you're answering this
question i'll ask the
the next group of people so that will be
saku and dorian to get ready
so the question came from deepak he said
object oriented and functional
programming are two paradigms
having knowledge of both them is really
good in a simple example
as this i actually found the original
object-oriented approach may be more
readable
but just to be sure functional
programming is really beneficial
do you have based on your experience
some examples where you would just say
go with functional programming as a as
something that people could look into
i mean from my experience whenever i've
adopted this approach
it has benefits on larger scale programs
so especially if you're not so used to
functional programming
then it can be a bit confusing and
like you say maybe in this example the
code is slightly simpler to understand
at least in the initial version of the
code before you add
undo and replay if you're adding undoing
replay with the imperative style it
would be
really quite messy to get that right and
so we even in this small case we can see
some benefits of the functional
style in terms of an example of
where this is really really powerful
that we've used is
in the sorcery code base the refactoring
engine is almost entirely functional and
it's 15 000 lines of code
and there's a huge number of tests of
that and if there was
and having it split out like that
with something well the thing about
sorcery is
it has to be correct we can't ever break
your code
and so having something that's really
reliable is very very important
and the way that we've structured the
code in this functional style
allows us to test it from end to end
very easily with
any of the different inputs any
different type of code that we need
and we found it to be extremely reliable
sorcery
tends to have almost no bugs in the core
engine and all the bugs that we tend to
find are in
the imperative wrappers that are around
the edge so
the integration into vs code or pycharm
or the github bot that's where we find
the bugs
are so in my experience it works very
very well but it does take some
practice to get used to this style of
writing code definitely